at this Market in address in eastern
chart the Sudanese pound is accepted
alongside the French franc
Sudanese refugees unable to receive Food
Aid come here to buy
business is risk for Safa Mizani
she says prices have tripled in the past
few weeks and blames major dealers of
exploitation
the major dealers are responsible for
the high prices there's no way we make
good profit the main Supply Route has
been cut off by the fighting in Sudan
she says Supply is nowhere near demand
Refugee Ahmed Muhammad could afford
three meals a day back in West Darfur
before the crisis
not anymore
we are forced to eat half rations
because of inflation things have become
so difficult
well the flood season threatening to cut
off the last Supply Route official say
shortages and inflation will increase
conditions have grown worse for local
people and Aid agencies are stepping in
I've honestly never seen such a big
operation so poorly funded we need just
wfp we need 13 million every month to
feed those people so far in three months
we have received 14. now we are already
on the edge where we will not be able to
provide them a meal a day
Chad has been hosting refugees from
Sudan for more than 20 years but vital
resources including food and water are
running low and many here fear that
could lead to violence between those who
are being sheltered and their hosts
and as refugees continue to cross the
border many fear tensions of the people
here or rise even further
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera adre on the
church Sudan border